Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go
to Jack from Minnesota. Jack, welcome.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. How are you doing?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Speaker 2: So I've been kind of wondering this all
my my entire political, you know, since I got into
politics. How genuine are some of the people
on the right? Because you have people like Ben
SHAPIRO, who's a Harvard grad, etc., etc.. He
should know that he is lying to his audiences,
you know, every day. Or or is there a possibility
that he just believes the things he believes in?
Speaker 1: Well, I think it depends on which
issue. I mean, I think that there's probably
some areas where there's a genuine belief and some
areas where there's like a knowing exaggeration.
I think it's an issue by issue thing.
Speaker 2: Okay. Yeah. Because I've just
been wondering because I just genuinely don't
know if there's a method in the madness of
some of these people.
Speaker 1: Yeah. It's you know, I think
it's for me, it's more interesting rather than
the media people. It's more interesting like when
when you see interviews at a Trump rally and the
people just parrot all the same stuff that these
people say, like, oh, the election was stolen and
the raid was illegal and Benghazi and Hillary and
Obamacare and all this stuff. Like, do they
remember do they even know that they're being,
you know, drifted and lied to? Or are they genuine
believers? That's a more difficult question to
answer to me and also a more interesting one.
Speaker 2: Okay? Yeah, it is. I guess that's
all is. Thank you for taking my call. All right.
Speaker 1: Thanks, Jack. Jack from Minnesota
with a beautiful question.